prince harry is ready to tell his story
on monday
book publisher penguin random house
announced they would be publishing a new
memoir written by the duke of sussex
here's what we know according to the
press release we can expect the book to
hit shelves sometime in 2022
it goes on to say that for the first
time terry plans to share the definitive
account of the experiences
adventures losses and life lessons that
have helped shape him
the prince also released a statement
about the forthcoming memoir
harry wrote i've worn many hats over the
years both literally and figuratively
and my hope is that in telling my story
the highs and lows
the mistakes the lessons learned i can
help show that no matter where we come
from
we have more in common than we think
harry goes on to call the memoir
a first-hand account of my life that's
accurate and
wholly truthful in addition we learned
harry will donate proceeds to charity
the announcement comes just weeks after
harry and william reunited
following a tense year in their
relationship well this has been a very
highly anticipated reunion because of
course it is the first time that we've
seen
the brothers on their own since
the fallout the brothers attended the
unveiling ceremony for a statue of their
mother princess diana
on what would have been her 60th
birthday well i thought harry looked
particularly jovial
i mean he was smiling for most of the
time william looked a little bit more
serious but
was still smiling and of course they
were very aware
that there was a camera and a
photographer trained on them for the
whole time
certainly it is it is harry's hope and i
think williams as well
that there will be a point where the
relationship is
is better harry has said himself that he
loves his brother but he recognizes that
it's going to take
time to heal and speaking to sources
close to william
i think it is going to take some time
the duke of cambridge is still
very bitter and very hurt by a lot of
what harry and megan said in that
interview
particularly those allegations of racism
that were leveled against the royal
family
so clearly it's going to take far more
than the funeral of their grandfather
and indeed the unveiling of this statue
i think for the relationship to be
anywhere near what it once was and
possibly it's ambitious
to expect that it ever will be what it
once was but i think they both recognize
that a fracture that divides key and
important members of the royal family
is something that can only be ultimately
damaging
to the monarchy i think there is every
chance that we will see the brothers
back together again but that may not be
for some time with the
covert pandemic of course with the
relationship i think still being
under some strain and it may not be
until june when it's widely expected
that the sussexes will be back for the
queen's platinum
jubilee celebrations to mark her 70th
year on the throne when it is expected
that all of her family will be there to
celebrate this milestone